مشاهدينا دعوه للمبارزه الجسديه تبادلها
رئيسات تويتر ومتى
المليارديران الى ماسك ومارك زوكربيرج
عبر حسناء ممازحه او كانت مزحه على ما
يبدو للعراق قائلا انا جاهز للقتال مارك
زوكربيرج رد على ماسك طالبا منه ارسال
موقع المبارزه ليرد الاخير قائلا من فيغاس
او فيغاس
حلب للمصارعه الشهيره اثار طبعا تبادل
الرسائل موجه ردود على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي اضافه الى
مراعاه الفائز المحتمل مع تصدر واضح لمارك
زوكربيرج في تكهنات بالنسبه للمنتصر منهما
شو رايك يا ابراهيم راح ينتصر
مثل باقي التوقعات لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات